President Trump tweeted this morning
that we should not be surprised by his
decision to withdraw some 2000 US troops
from Syria the president claims that
they have defeated Isis there and other
countries need to step up but his
announcement yesterday was condemned by
many of his Republican supporters David
Martin is at the Pentagon where
officials are making plans for the
withdrawal David good morning good
morning the president's decision is
drawing criticism from members of his
own party and from within his own
administration one senior administration
official tells CBS News it's a
catastrophic disaster but one voice of
approval came from a Russian Foreign
Ministry spokesman who said it creates
real prospects for a political solution
to Syria's Civil War we have one against
Isis we've beaten them and we've beaten
them badly even as president Trump
declared victory he faced friendly fire
from fellow Republicans who say he's
retreating the colossal on my mind
mistake a grave error it's caught
everybody off guard and will eventually
pay for it here even Lindsey Graham
usually a supporter of President Trump
called the move a mistake were
dramatically less safe this is an Obama
life move candidate Donald Trump had
criticized President Obama for his 2011
decision to pull US troops out of Iraq
which some say paved the way for the
rise of Isis Isis is honoring President
Obama he is the founder of Isis the
territory Isis once held in Syria the
so-called Caliphate has been reduced to
just a few pockets but the fighting
remains fierce with special operations
forces calling in hundreds of strikes
last week on Isis positions senior
administration officials have predicted
it would take a couple more months to
clear the last pockets and warned that
would not be the end of it I think it's
fair to say Americans will remain on the
ground after the physical defeat of the
Caliphate until we have the pieces in
place to ensure that that defeat is in
we estimate for example about 35 to
40,000 local forces have to be trained
in equipped in order to provide
stability it turned out the only
statement that counted was one the
president made last spring I want to get
out I want to bring our trips back home
I want to start rebuilding our nation
defense officials say they will try to
get all troops out of Syria within 30
days and that airstrikes and artillery
strikes will be used to cover their
withdrawal after that it will be up to
other countries with troops on the
ground in Syria to carry on the fight vo
no one country that is picking up that
mantle is Russia David thank you